[inaudible].
All right.
We are on location at the blaze studios here in Dallas,
Texas.
And I'm sitting across from Mr [inaudible],
Glenn Beck or sir,
how's it going?
My man.
Good to see you.
Thank you for letting us do an on location shoot.
Not a problem.
I know you're here for about 10 minutes and then you're,
I think you're going to probably be on the moon and then a stop at the Mars and
you know a little bit about traveling a lot.
Yeah.
So I'm in between a thousand things here.
Uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's pretty cool.
I want to spend a lot of time talking about this book here,
addicted to outrage.
Um,
but let's just do everything.
So right now we're about two and a half weeks away from this mid term election.
I suspect something completely bananas over the next two and a half weeks.
I mean,
you can already just see between,
between the cabinet stuff that we've been dealing with,
the general outrage and all the things you're writing about here.
So here,
I just said this to a group of friends the other day.
I think at this point a spaceship could appear.
Okay.
And,
and hover over New York City and to be like,
Huh.
I mean I don't know what would surprise me now.
Well we'd be arguing about the gender pronouns at the aliens.
Yeah,
I know.
It's,
it's absolutely insane how everything is,
everything is upside down.
Everything is upside down.
Do you think,
do you think we're in a unique time because that's one of the questions when I'm
out there with Peterson,
often people say,
okay,
it's,
you know,
everyone says we've never been more partisan and were angrier than ever and all
of these things.
But does something about this seem unique?
Yeah,
I I'm a,
I'm a glutton for history.
Yes.
And uh,
it,
we have been in perilous times before.
I don't think we've hit the civil war,
uh,
confrontations yet,
but we are approaching it.
Do you think we really are?
Cause I do,
cause I'm actually worried about the amount of people I used to see this on
Twitter all the time.
People saying,
oh,
civil wars come in,
you know,
like it's like murmur about what would be the most horrific possible outcome of
all that.
So remind me to talk about the window cause I think we have a window right now.
Um,
but we have been,
uh,
we've been worse.
I mean,
if you look at Jefferson and Adams,
you know,
Adams Adams was called a Hermaphrodite by Jefferson Jefferson.
Jefferson.
Uh,
his campaign,
uh,
um,
called him a hermaphrodite.
Adam said back that if you elect Thomas Jefferson,
there will be blood in the streets and the heads of our children and your
daughters will be on Pike's into every town.
So we've had rhetoric like this.
Ironically,
I'd be thrilled to vote for either one
would be like,
I'll take either,
I don't care heads on pikes,
that would be fine.
But it all does go to,
in the last couple of weeks,
you know,
there was this Hillary Clinton Lion on CNN talking to Christiane Amanpour about
how we can't be civil because these,
these people,
meaning the Conservatives or Republicans are so against our values.
I mean,
this is dangerous stuff.
Here's the difference.
Um,
we have been in these places before,
but we knew our founding documents.
We knew who we served or who our God was.
And I don't know who our God is now.
I mean,
is it money?
Is it fame?
Is it anger?
I don't know what our God is now.
Um,
we knew,
wait,
can you wait,
let me pause you there for a sec.
So when you,
when you say that about what the founders believed now,
they were also saying separation of church and state the whole time.
So if you were just laying out what they believed when you say we knew who our
guide was,
um,
so George Washington,
they did believe in the division of Church and state.
Clearly I do too.
Yeah.
Um,
that just means if you're an atheist,
you're an atheist.
We're friends,
we're cool,
let's get along.
But if you're a god person,
you'll do your God's thing.
You do your atheist thing.
Do we have what Adam Smith called moral sentiment in common?
Yes.
Capitalism,
uh,
has lost the first volume of Adam Smith.
The second volume is wealth of nations.
The first volume is moral sentiments.
And that says,
look,
this is an invisible hand and the market is powerful and it will create whatever
you want.
Be careful what you ask for.
Make sure you are always tempering the moral sentiment.
Make sure that you're good,
decent,
fair minded people.
We've lost that.
We're losing it,
I should say.
Um,
and I'm concerned,
and I talk about this a bit in the book.
I've seen this coming for almost two decades and I have been warning against it.
And for the very first time I'm at the place where I'm on the air now saying,
this is the time.
This is the time that I said would come.
Yeah.
And now is the time for you to remember who you are.
Um,
and our outrage is taking us away from it.
So as I've looked at this for so long,
I have,
I have studied revolutions.
I've studied giant movements of chaos.
I,
I can tell you about,
you know,
uh,
the,
um,
I think it was the red month,
uh,
in the 1930s.
Like,
I can show you what's happened,
but there were three people in four people in grand movements that have gotten
it right.
There was Abraham Lincoln,
there was Martin Luther King.
There was Gandhi.
Then there's Bonhoeffer,
Bonhoeffer.
Do you know who Dietrich Bonhoeffer was?
I don't think so.
Bonhoeffer lost.
Okay.
Bonhoeffer was a,
um,
a,
uh,
pastor I think Lutheran in Germany.
He,
uh,
was on the air when the fear of declared he was fear he was taking,
his broadcast was cutting short because he was doing a broadcast called the
[inaudible] principle.
This is wrong.
Don't go this way.
He on Kristallnacht.
The very next morning he was shopping in those stores,
those Jewish stores,
um,
pacifist.
He tried to turn the Germans back and say,
stop it.
Stop.
You're going the wrong way.
He couldn't do it.
He eventually escaped from,
uh,
Germany was in New York,
not here very long as he felt guilty.
How can I leave my country when it's in this much trouble?
He went back.
He realized there's no,
the noise has stopped.
This guy may be violence is the answer he was involved in.
Um,
one of the attempts to kill,
um,
Hitler,
he went to a concentration camp.
He died.
He was executed like five days before Hitler died.
Here's the thing,
if you read his writings,
he's gone to,
he's Jesus.
He's Martin Luther King.
He's,
he's,
he's got it and that every,
read them and read them and read them.
How,
why did he fail?
Silence in the face of evil is evil itself not to stand is to stand.
He's got it.
Love one another.
Don't stop playing the organ so you can hear the,
the train going down.
Twits okay.
He failed because Germans had already gone over the cliff.
They had because of World War One,
then the treaty of Versailles,
then the 1920s,
they had already lost their Judeo Christian principles.
They had lost their center.
Remember,
if it wasn't for England,
Gandhi would have failed.
People think of Gandhi is starving himself to get the British to comply.
No,
he starved himself to say to his own people do not rise up in anger.
They were this close to losing and he knew it.
He was appealing to the sense of decency and fairness of the British culture.
So he knew the people because of their Judeo Christian worldview would see this
oppression and go,
that's wrong.
If we have a window and it's closing,
if we give into our anger,
our outrage,
and we say,
you know what?
I can't take it anymore.
We will lose.
And that window of the Judeo Christian values will close and then we're done.
Yeah.
It's so interesting because one of the themes that keeps coming up as I'm on
this tour is people
keep asking me about this.
How much worse is it going to get before there's some sort of reset and all of
these things?
And it's like,
man,
I don't want two months from now or four years from now to look back at right
before the 2018 elections and go,
boy,
weren't those the good old days because we've gone on on the train to hell.
So do you think there's actually no way to stop it at this point?
Do you think that,
no,
I think they understood behind it.
So here's,
here's the scenarios that I'm looking at right now.
If I'm war gaming.
Yeah.
Okay.
None of these,
I know the prediction business always works out.
So let's see here.
I got it.
So if you're wargaming yeah,
let's look at the next election.
What happens?
Well,
the Democrats probably gonna win the house.
Okay?
They win the house.
You know,
they're going to at least subpoena his tax records.
He's not going to give up tax records that'll be brought to the supreme court.
Remember that marker number one,
that's day number one.
Day number two,
they don't have any place they can go on impeachment.
They have to impeach him.
Even if they don't have anything.
They've already said it.
They have to do,
they have to do it.
It'll be the senate that will throw,
they'll throw it to the senate.
That's where the trial happens.
So impeachment just means or taking you to court.
Okay?
So that's day number two.
Day number three,
uh,
Trump has already filed with the Supreme Court saying,
I'm not,
I'm not testifying,
I'm not turning over my tax records.
I'm not doing this.
Okay.
Well Cavanaugh has already said he's already seen that that's a distraction the
president shouldn't have to.
So day number three,
when Trump has brought it to the Supreme Court,
then the house says,
wait a minute,
Cavenaugh should recuse himself.
We are looking at a year where,
uh,
the three branches of government,
the administration,
uh,
plus the house and the Senate,
both of them will be fighting with each other.
They'll be fighting with this branch and there'll be fighting with the supreme
court.
When Cavenaugh doesn't recuse himself,
they will file articles of impeachment for him.
And they're,
they're leading all of these ideas already.
I mean,
these ideas are trickling out of this.
Yeah.
So now you have the press.
The fourth branch already in chaos has,
has absolutely no credibility at all.
It's deranged.
And that pushes which you would call the fifth branch for the first branch,
the people into the streets.
How do you solve that?
All right,
so before we get to the streets,
can I give you the one option that I think maybe saves us from all of that,
which is that the Republicans win,
or at least hold in the mid terms.
Thus finally as long shot is,
this is finally the Democrats go,
okay,
we've got to drop identity politics.
We've got to get away from this socialist Democrat,
Democrat,
socialist.
Not that I,
there's no evidence that they would ever look in the mirror if anything,
they've only doubled down every time.
But I see that as the only outlet to where you are.
So I think if you have,
if they don't win the house,
if you win the house,
God forbid if they win the house and the Senate,
then it's chaos.
But if you win,
if they win the house,
the Democrats,
that scenario is going to play out in some form or another.
So that just gets worse and worse and worse.
I was talking to a friend of mine just last night about this and he said,
you know,
just exactly what you said,
and I followed it up with what you said.
Show me the,
I know there's no evidence I am Spartacus is all of a sudden going to say,
okay,
I'm not Spartacus.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm the carpenter from,
you know,
from Nazareth.
Now,
wasn't that the danger all along and this,
this is directly linked to your book.
I mean,
I remember before the election I kept saying,
yeah,
this is when I still considered myself on the left.
And someone that had basically only voted Democrat my entire life.
I think the one time I voted Republican was a Bloomberg's third term in New York
City after he had flipped like 87 times over or something.
I'm not even sure if he was a republican at that point.
Um,
but that I kept saying before the election,
if you keep calling Trump Hitler,
then no matter what he does and no matter what reality is,
you'll never be able to get yourself out of that little thing place you've
painted yourself.
And that's where we are.
So,
you know,
it's crazy.
I lived this,
I lived this.
I said,
I'm the guy who got in so much trouble saying,
I think Barack Obama may be a racist.
Now I immediately corrected it in that on the spot and said,
that's not quite right.
I now understand.
I explain it in the book.
I now understand how to express that.
I wasn't up on anti colonialism.
I certainly wasn't up on postmodernism.
I wasn't.
So I'm hearing all these terms that mean nothing to me and yet they're always
attacking groups to me and to a lot of people in the country.
That's the definition of racist.
Okay.
But I didn't understand the difference.
The other part,
the other part of it,
okay,
it's now social justice.
Okay,
well social justice seems wrong to me.
That's how I defined it then.
That was so divisive when I said that.
And I was really at the time struggling to figure out what is happening.
How is,
who is this guy?
Um,
and I got more and more strident,
uh,
and
didn't make a lot of friends on the left.
Okay.
Yeah,
it didn't work.
It didn't work.
My base got stronger,
my bass learned things.
But my base also as things went on,
got more and more angry as did I,
why isn't this working?
Well,
because you cannot call people names and expect them to come over.
We have,
I just saw new poll today that shows,
I think it's 8% of the American public.
8,000 people interviewed 8% of the American public is the die hard.
Progressive.
Radical.
Okay.
Um,
the,
uh,
the never give up conservative.
Traditional conservative is about 29%.
Okay.
They're both on the edges.
27,
29%,
somewhere in that area.
Still on the edges.
The vast majority is now being called the exhausted class and it's the class of
people and I'm in this guys,
it doesn't have to be this way.
I don't,
I'm tired of this.
I know.
Not Everybody is a racist.
Not everybody is a homophobe.
This the stop it.
Stop it.
The cabinet Jordan Peterson got into trouble and I tweeted,
I tweeted back to him.
I think this might be the first time I disagree,
but I put I think because,
well for people that didn't see it,
basically he said that would probably be best.
And he did this in a tweet,
which is never the best way to do it.
Idea.
And He's already,
he's already had his mayor Koch on that and released a correct not correction,
a clarification in a blog form.
Uh,
but basically he said the best outcome would be the cabinet gets confirmed but
then steps down.
And what he meant was that wasn't saying the Cavenaugh did do anything or didn't
do anything.
But if there's any chance for a little bit of healing where everyone gets a
little egg on their face but also gets a little bit of dignity to walk away with
and the country doesn't come apart at the seams.
That was what he tried to do in a tweet.
And in his blog posts,
he's acknowledged that trying to do that in a tweet,
probably not the best thing.
Trying to do that in a tweet.
Um,
where the people who are reading it are generally all about politics and tearing
each other apart.
Yeah.
Bad idea.
That's why I put I think because knowing Jordan the little that I do,
yeah,
he's a deep philosophical thinker.
So my,
my feeling was,
and it turns out it was right that he's looking at that and saying,
okay,
in,
in a normal world,
in a good world where we're all really trying to do the right thing.
And if we really were all trying to do the right thing,
I agree with him,
it would have been the best thing to have Jordan say or to have Kevin.
I'll say thank you.
Thank you.
Now let's bring the country back together.
Nominate somebody else and let's go through.
But the other side would have gone through exactly the same thing.
You would have rewarded them in the end.
Cause I got it.
Because we're talking about the machines of destruction.
So reality doesn't play a role.
At some point,
this 70% of America is going to stand up and say,
shut up.
Both of you
shocked how many people in that 70% are just afraid to do that because when we
do these meet and greets after the Peterson events,
I think the number one question I get asked is what can I do?
I'm afraid to speak and I cannot,
I mean I see this,
you know,
from people that I'm sitting this close to and I see this look in their eyes a
fear.
And it's like,
I don't think I'm that brave.
I don't know why I'm doing this.
I don't,
I'm just doing it.
I can't explain it,
but I don't wake up every morning and I'm like,
what am I going to do today to fight Google and fight the political powers?
And I'm just like,
I'm just doing what I think is right.
That's it.
That,
so that goes to,
I brought my family thousand 11 to Auschwitz and I did it again because I see
over the horizon I think.
And we stood outside of the gates and um,
we had a prayer and then I said,
okay,
we are here because we have to look at the ugliest thing man has done.
And we have to decide who we are,
who we're going to be.
Because if you weren't prepared,
and I don't mean prepare for that kind of stuff,
I mean really know who you are.
You will not stand when the jackbooted thugs come down the street.
You have to know who you are and what you believe.
So I had them read a story of the righteous of the nation.
They could pick anyone who saved Jews and really try to get into their head.
I lined up and uh,
a just a family kind of conversation with this sweet woman.
She just died I think last week.
She's 90 years old.
She was a Christian.
She was 16 years old.
When she saved the first Jew.
Her whole family did it.
It was remarkable.
Um,
and we,
we talked about it.
Two things I learned on that trip.
One as we were leaving,
I said to her,
look,
I have a responsibility that's different than most because I speak to so many
people.
And I said,
I believe that people have that tree of righteousness in them.
I think they have that goodness.
They want to do the right thing.
How do I water it?
She told me something so profound.
It's so game changing.
She,
she looked at me so puzzled and she said,
you misunderstand.
The righteous didn't suddenly become righteous.
They just refused to go over the cliff with the rest of humanity.
All you have to do is remember what you've always believed was true and they
just stand and just go,
hmm,
no,
you guys are crazy.
You don't have to be a hero.
You're not a hero.
She was looking at me.
She wouldn't let me film or she only let me take one picture of her.
She wanted to nothing because she's like,
I'm not a hero.
I just remembered what was right.
That's remarkable.
Do you that the default position
of humanity is to cower?
That is that in these moments it seems like it's a lot easier to cower,
right?
I mean,
even now,
like that's the thing.
When people say this to me about w how do I get brave or whatever,
it's like we live in the freest place in the history of the world.
Need bravery.
And if you're,
if you're afraid now imagine the second that thing gets turned a little bit
about how afraid you are going to be.
So it seems like,
like fear and,
and I'm sure there's a psychological component to this that fear does something
in the brain that may be bravery or,
or maybe it really is about just knowing what you are and what your,
let me tell you two stories.
Um,
uh,
first fear shuts your brain down.
Okay.
It's shuts reason down.
You're in fight or flight and that's a good thing because you don't want to be
going,
well I don't know.
Should I hit him a little harder?
You're just swinging.
So fear and anger really bad and that's why we're addicted.
Outrage.
We will swing yet.
Got To get shaped that or your won't think it's biological.
Two stories.
Um,
the other person we met with in Poland was the chief rabbi and he said,
I think it was 7,000.
There were 7,000 people that stood.
And I was,
I mean when you,
have you been out with,
no,
I have it.
When you go,
there's churches.
I mean a block away.
Yeah.
There were houses everywhere and they're old.
They were there and why I left there and I was enraged.
I remember crying and,
and looking at the houses and screaming in my head,
where the hell were you?
Where were you?
Okay.
I meet with him and I said,
how out of all the millions of people,
and he said,
yeah,
yeah.
You're thinking,
that's a small number.
You said that's an incredible number of people.
People,
you're in a scary movie.
You look away when something like this is coming.
It is human nature to look away or to dismiss and you,
it's,
it's um,
we have this gift of fear that warns us,
but we use logic and sometimes we use it just to protect ourselves because Dave,
I don't think people are afraid of standing.
I think they're afraid of knowing the truth.
You look at the people who stand,
the people who stand are the ones who are going,
you know,
I learned something new.
I learned something.
It's changed me.
They're not standing.
You're not standing cause you're brave and I'm going to take a stand.
You're saying,
wait a minute,
I just scales fell off my eyes.
I just learned something.
When you are inquisitive.
Yeah.
When you are based in,
wait a minute,
I I really want to know.
You have already prepared to,
yeah,
but do you really,
you and I,
I know you know this.
I think we've talked about it.
I went through it and you went through it.
You do come to a point to where you're saying,
if I take another step,
yeah.
Everything in my life could change.
My friends might change.
They might look at me differently.
And you take that step and say,
yeah,
I want to know the truth.
That's where people fail
the,
if you can't take that leap,
and that's why I really think you're seeing people like you.
You're seeing the inquisitive because that's in their nature to question
question,
wait a minute.
That doesn't make sense.
And if you're like that,
you most likely have already passed that line of uncomfortability because you've
had things that you realize that you went,
oh crap.
Okay,
well I guess I don't believe that anymore.
Yeah.
You don't know how I could wake up and put stuff in my hair and look in the
mirror and go.
That's why I just don't know how I could do it,
but I know some people do it and then I get,
I think this is what Jordan would describe as sort of the slow road to hell.
You will just diminish yourself in diminish yourself every every day of your
life until the end.
Yeah.
You have to stop looking.
You have to turn around because it will always present you with the option.
Oh,
you sought,
you looked out and you saw them just lining up a family of Jews shooting them.
Okay.
Now what do you do once you see it?
It presents you with the choice.
Yeah.
Do I go back to sleep or do I stand
so I know every,
you know,
it's very easy to always be like,
okay,
both sides are going crazy.
They're equally horrible and all of those things like that.
Sort of like the easy,
the easy way of doing it.
I'm not saying that that's what you're doing here,
but that's sort of the easy way to do it.
And we all fall in that trap sometimes,
right?
Because just for brevity sake,
sometimes it's easier to say that,
but it seems to me that for all the people that,
that absolutely despise Trump,
that,
that hate everything about the right,
the right basically has been in power for the last two years.
There's a lot of good things happening in the country related to economics and
the fact that we're not entering foreign wars.
And there's some interesting things happening with North Korea in a series of
other things.
And the state has not used its power to silence anyone.
What I fear,
and this is why I don't think it's an even,
oh,
both sides are crazy thing,
is that the left is about state power.
And what I fear is they've said,
or half of the country's Nazis,
we cannot be civil with them because they're coming to get us.
And if these people took power,
well now we have everything that you just laid out because they don't mind using
the apparatus of the state,
right.
To accomplish their goals.
And I'm not saying Republicans are always write about this stuff and they,
they screw up all
the little government things that they should care about.
And all of that,
the left has become everything.
They said the tea party was okay,
that we weren't,
we weren't,
um,
they have become violent.
They have become unreasonable.
They want to silence people and they will silence people.
That's why you're seeing people start,
begin to stand up and say,
ha,
um,
however,
it's one of my fears with Donald Trump.
And the great thing is he says a lot and most of it never happens.
You know what I mean?
My fear is,
um,
he has said,
you know,
maybe we should look into the license of these companies.
You know,
I don't think he means it,
but you signal that to people on the right or the left your,
you're basically saying,
yeah,
that's on the,
that's on the field of play.
It's not on the field of play.
Um,
although there's an interesting libertarian argument whether the government
should be giving licensing.
No,
no,
no.
I don't think he should have licensed at all.
Right,
right,
right.
I don't,
I certainly don't want the government to say,
you know what,
you've been a little harsh,
so I'm going to look into your license.
No,
right.
Not at all.
Get him out of that.
Here's the,
here's the thing that people aren't thinking about.
Government is about to become,
unless it marries into it,
pretty inconsequential because it will never be able to keep up with technology.
So it was that the saving grace here?
No,
not,
not that.
I was going to give Google a Lotta.
The left is concentrating their power in silicon valley and that's where you can
really silence people.
The guy who wrote,
um,
IBM and the Holocaust,
gosh,
I can't remember his name.
Really Brilliant Guy.
Well thought out.
Um,
we were talking and um,
we were talking about how the Germans,
how they silence people and how they,
they coordinate people off and then just get smaller and smaller groups.
And then they eventually put you behind a wall in a ghetto.
Well,
they would build the wall higher and higher so people couldn't hear or see.
Isn't that what Google and Facebook are doing?
We're building digital ghettos.
We have the ability now you can speak all you want Dave,
but I'm changing the algorithm and you're not going to be heard.
I mean,
you look at what the deal with Facebook was.
I promote them.
I give them my 10 million listeners and I say,
Hey,
you can find me at Facebook.
Let's communicate.
Then they take those listeners that said,
I want to hear from him.
Yeah,
and then they changed the algorithm and I can't communicate to my own people.
and know this is happening across
the board.
You probably saw my insane tweet thread about all of that.
I just started re tweeting all of these people,
real people,
not Russian bots and avatars.
I was taking purposely real people with real names or real pictures and they're
all saying they're unsubscribed.
There were people who pay.
It wasn't just the free people,
it was the people who pay for youtube red or youtube TV still getting
unsubscribed and it's like,
what did we all sign up for here?
But dare I do you like the biblical analogies?
I'll do one here.
There was David versus Goliath and I think Dave can take down Google
this.
Dave,
I think there's a chance,
I mean,
I think that story,
I'm being slightly hyperbolic obviously,
but I think that these things have become so big.
I mean,
this I guess is what the essence of the story was,
right?
That this Goliath,
this Google has become so big that it will crumble under its own,
under the weight of its own crap,
basically.
That there will be enough people inside the broken machine that will wake up
that help that individuals basically.
I hope all you got is hope,
right?
Yeah.
And you're your three to five years away from it being a cage.
I mean,
their behavior with China,
which I outlined in the book is pretty horrific.
Um,
what China,
what the road China is going down is terrifying and Google is right there with
them.
Um,
and that is evil.
That is evil.
They say don't be evil.
Well that is the definition of it.
Um,
and if they just slowly,
you know,
the guy who closes the door on the gas chamber was most likely a guy that was
fixing trucks before the war and a normal guy,
you don't suddenly become evil.
You slowly move into it.
It,
especially if you're surrounded by a group of people that are all absolutely
convinced that they are right and the other voice is wrong and therefore we just
have to filter them out with AI and the way they are gobbling,
um,
it's really disturbing and the problem is going to happen.
You know,
we're going to start hitting,
um,
massive job loss,
probably 20,
20,
21,
22.
That's when you're going to really start to feel the effects of,
of Ai.
Um,
when that happens,
if you look at history and we know it,
all the politicians now are saying,
I'm going to get those jobs back from China.
You're not because they're leaving China because they're getting too expensive
in China.
So you're not getting those jobs back.
And especially because a AI and robotics are are growing.
We'll have 30% unemployment by 2030 30% permanent unemployment.
So you look at this,
what to politicians always do?
They got to find a bad guy.
Well,
right now it's China,
but as soon as people realize that,
wait a minute,
it's silicon valley that's taking my jobs.
The politician then says it's those people,
those people that are building the robots.
Unless those people also see over the horizon and become buddy buddy with their
friends in Washington and they work together,
then you have a a surveillance state that I don't think we ever get out of.